good evening good evening I'm so glad to
see all of you here today and I'd like
to welcome you to the 2018 Henry Louis
Gates Jr annual lecture my name is
Jacqueline Goldsby I'm a professor of
English in African American Studies and
I'm also chair of African American
Studies here at Yale as many of you know
but for those of you who are attending
this event for the first time the gates
lecture marks the capstone of African
American Studies academic year partly
because the event literally as you know
if you're a student or a faculty member
here this this day closes out our year
of public programming and on that point
I want to thank all of you for spending
your time on this last day of classes to
attend tonight's talk and I think you'll
be glad that you did but more
importantly the gates lecture is
particularly occasion for our department
because these talks give us a chance to
think incisively about the largest
issues and decisive developments that
shape the field of African American and
black diaspora studies for the past six
years the Gates lecture has brought such
world-renowned scholars as a philosopher
Kwame Anthony Appiah
the dramatist poet critic in Nobel
laureate Walachia Jenka the legal
theorist Patricia Williams black
feminist theorists and literary critic
core tenets pillars sociologist Dorothy
Roberts and our distinguished lecturer
today David Scott who my colleague Kogan
immerser will introduce shortly all of
these scholars come to share their
newest original work with us and we're
thrilled with by the in honor to have
this opportunity to think with them here
in our community this series also allows
us to open those discussion as broadly
as possible to include colleagues and
students across Yale's campus and from
the New Haven community and colleagues
in the region and this spirit of
research writing and teaching as
Fellowship is community building we
honor the example of the scholar after
whom the series is named Henry Louis
Gates Jr whose pioneering literary
criticism theory and archival recovery
projects have been like our lecturers
scholarship foundational
for african-american and black diaspora
studies and indeed liberal arts inquiry
as such so on behalf of the department
I'm thrilled to welcome you today to
join our work to organize an event like
this requires a communal effort and I
want to give thanks to the Yale staff
colleagues and units that have made
today possible in African American
Studies I want to thank Lisa Monroe
jasmine Williams and Edith Piaf you've
done so much to build up the kind of
organizational infrastructure to make
this year's lecture happen in every year
[Music]
I also want to thank our thank our
colleagues here at the Whitney
Humanities Center director Gary
Tomlinson and his staff and particularly
Tony sudol who orchestrates so much of
the a/v here every year they go out they
graciously collaborate with us to host
the lecture in this interdisciplinary
space and I want to thank Gary and his
staff for that speaking of space and
fellowship I just want to remind you all
that following professor Scott's lecture
will host a reception in room 108 which
is just down the hall and we welcome
everyone to continue the conversation
that I know professor Scott stock will
generate over really nice food and
drinks so you're welcome to join us
then finally we owe a very tremendous
special thanks to Daniel and Joanna Rose
who created the endowment funds for at
the gates lecture series mr. Rose as he
is every year is here with us today and
I want to acknowledge you for your
support
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's important to acknowledge just
how much the roses do for Yale and the
work of african-american studies indeed
their support for this lecture series
reflects their long-held commitments to
education mr. and mrs. rose support a
remarkable range of projects here at
Yale among them
the OU libraries Fortin off Holocaust
survivors video archive Rose Walk which
is the library plazas space that was
once High Street and urban studies in
the place the roses call home New York
City mr. rose found it in his chairman
emeritus of the highly acclaimed Harlem
educational activities fund which
provides educational and scholarship
support to place black and Latino
students and leading colleges and
universities across the United States
he's also a prolific essayist in his own
right he publishes regularly about race
labor and economics and education in the
Harlem Times a newspaper he founded and
publishes in print and online and again
he comes here every year and he studies
the work of the speakers that we invite
and he asked some of the most incisive
questions at dinner as all of us who
know you now know so thank you again for
your support
and now to introduce this use gates
lecturer I'd like to welcome my
colleague covin immerser professor of
african-american studies in the history
of art well good evening everyone I'm
delighted to introduce our speaker this
evening David Scott who is professor and
chair of anthropology at Columbia
University where he's been based since
1999 so David Scott is a leading figure
in post-colonial criticism as his
scholarship has tackled cultural
political and philosophical questions of
global concern through a critical lens
that has redefined the Caribbean
Anglophone francophone spanish-speaking
and more besides as a uniquely
intersectional space through his books
his articles and journal work over the
last 20 years
Scott's intellectual commitments have
sharpened the relevance of Caribbean
studies to African American Studies
American studies anthropology diaspora
studies and the humanities as a whole so
his central project is one that asked
the following question how do the
humanities today contribute to rewriting
the history of the present whether we
call it genealogy archaeology or the
world historical conjuncture this is
really the driving concern at the heart
of his work it's a question that Scott
first posed in his 1994 book
refashioning futures criticism after
post coloniality by reframing the post
not as marking the end of the colonial
era but demanding new ways to seize hold
of Futurity in the face of intransigent
global injustice 'as he's asking how did
we get to where we are today so as to
then ask how do we get out what
strategies enable us to move
towards a usable future conscripts of
modernity was published in 2004 and it
tackled this question by rereading CLR
James's Magisterial narrative of the
Haitian Revolution black jacobins an
entirely fresh light whereas
anti-colonialist
saw freedom struggle as a story of
overcoming and redemption Scot argued
that our need to reconnect requires a
shift from the narrative art of romance
to that of tragedy what comes into view
as a result of this shift is that black
freedom struggles since the Haitian
Revolution have been inescapably
affected by the hazards of contingency
the ups and downs of history and have
also faced new forms of racialized
eminent domination that we cannot
account for when the plot structure of
romance determines our expectations of
resolution and closure so this and other
works have had immense impact on
historiography on political philosophy
and really on the ethics of liberal arts
inquiry at large and those two books
were followed in 2014 by omens of
adversity in which Scot offered what he
called the theory of Haiti this is a
finely nuanced account of both the
centrality of slavery to the material
history of the modern West and it's
absent from collective memory resulting
in the common sense that we've inherited
today in which moral dilemmas are still
not yet addressed far less overcome and
in fact visitors to documents are 14
which is the survey of global
contemporary art that last year
exhibited the actual code noir documents
of 1685 those visitors would have heard
Scot distill his argument in a panel
discussion in which he argued that the
social death entailed by slavery
continues as we have ongoing and
irreparable consequences with demands
for justice that have not yet been met
and then standing behind all of this is
Scott's role in initiating
a small ax Journal of which is the
editor since its beginnings in 1997 when
it came out of the MoMA campus of
University of West Indies where Scott
studied for his first degree and later
taught before moving to Columbia this
flagship journal has redefined the field
of Caribbean studies as a whole
small axe has played a leading role in
both nurturing rising generations of
scholars artists and performers from the
region and it's multiple diasporas and
which is fully in keeping with the
commitments of a post-colonial as a
rewriting of the modern past the journal
has also become an indispensable
archival resource it's featured Scott's
probing interviews with successive
generations of West Indian thinkers from
Sylvia winter and Orlando Patterson to
Merle Collins
George lambing Rex nettle firt and
Stuart Hall so small axe has thoroughly
reshaped neighboring fields of study
over the past two decades which puts it
in line with SABIC ooh the 1960s Journal
of the Caribbean artists movement and
indeed presents African in the 1950s for
this achievement Scott received the 2016
distinguished editor award from the
Council of editors of Lerner to journals
and I'd also add that what makes small
acts uniquely distinctive is the way in
which it's consistently spotlighted
contemporary Caribbean visual arts and
this in fact includes a conference
that's upcoming in Miami next month
so professor Scott has been a member of
the Institute for Advanced Studies at
Princeton a visiting professor at the
Sorbonne and he's lectured worldwide in
London in Beirut and in Cape Town
amongst other places and in fact his
most recent book Stuart Hall's voice
which was published last year stemmed
from those lectures in South Africa so
while we're familiar with the way that
Hall is situated in relation to the
British knew left and in the context of
his dialogues with Western Marxism Scott
in his book of last year has expanded
the interpretive framework
we can think about Paul's contribution
to late twentieth century thought by
resituated in between the radical black
tradition as Cedric Robertson called it
and perhaps more unexpectedly in the
tradition of political philosophy
articulated by Hannah Arendt and her
unflinching engagement with the moral
dimension of a public intellectual life
so when we consider that many of halls
essays began life in spoken form what's
especially striking about the format in
which Scott pens his own dialogue with
Paul in the form of a series of letters
is the importance of the our realm of
listening and attentiveness it's in this
sonic medium that Scott theorizes what
he calls an ethics of receptive
generosity as the books like subtitle
has it and it's from this position that
he puts forward a dialogical model of
ethics the furthers our understanding of
the critical mode of inquiry that paul
represented so Scott is currently
working on a biography of Stuart core
this is a project authorized by the
Stuart Hall foundation and as this work
informs the topic that he'll be speaking
to this evening it'd be fair to say
there's been great anticipation
surrounding this lecture so we're
extremely fortunate in African American
Studies to have Professor Scott as our
speaker this evening and he's graciously
agreed to take questions their
microphones on either side of the
auditorium and as I reiterate Jackie's
invitation for you to join us in the
reception afterwards I ask you to please
join me in welcoming professor David
Scott to Yale
[Applause]
thank you very very much for that
introduction cabina it is a it is a very
very great pleasure to be here this
afternoon I would like to begin by
thanking Jackie for the invitation and
for doing me the honor of speaking here
I am deeply appreciative of the
generosity of mr. Daniel Rose who's who
has made the lecture series possible I
would also like to thank before I begin
Gary Tomlinson the the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center for hosting
the lecture and and of course I am too
very appreciative of Henry Louis Gates
in who's in whose name that the lectures
are offered a sense of displacement
Stuart Hall's art of living
what follows are emphatically notes
nothing more there are going to be four
of them they will I think be connected
more or less to each other but they may
not exactly add up to a no to an overall
coherent thesis not yet anyway
certainly they do not constitute a
systematic argument rather and in the
spirit of Stuart Hall's own
characteristic way of formulating what
he had to say they are meant to be
tentative and provisional and
exploratory really only points for
further elaboration and clarification
they are so to speak notes toward a long
album propo to the biography of Stuart
Hall that I am in the middle of thinking
and writing and yet nevertheless these
notes are not meant to be entirely
aimless they seek in their own way to
circle around the general theme of what
I'm going to call Stuart Hall's art of
living his distinctive self constitution
of a reflective thinking acting life a
self examining life his ingeniously
paradoxical project of self creation of
being becoming who in part he already
was self creation and self consciousness
were in him sides of a single whole a
good deal of what is simply remarkable
about Stuart Hall as an intellectual
he's already suggested here namely the
profound sense in which his thinking
came to bear the stamp of his life and
vice versa his life the stamp of his
thinking
what he professed and how he lived came
to have an intimate bearing on one
another now in recent years there has
emerged an instructive discussion of a
distinction between philosophy thought
of as an academic discipline and
philosophy understood as a way of life
in part at least are not so surprisingly
this discussion has emerged in response
to and in conversation with Michel
Foucault late preoccupations with a
contrast as always heuristic
experimental pencil in between what he
thought of as two branches of Western
philosophy one historically rooted
through the Delphic prescription to know
thyself and the other through the
Socratic notion of the care of the self
in a certain sense the former is the
branch that eventually comes to be
institutionalized as the theoretical
discipline of academic philosophy
characterized by a selectively
specialized training and authorization
an impersonal attitude of formal
detachment for the sake of objectivity
and a systematic and methodological
search for the truth by contrast the
latter orientation associated more
perhaps with literary or therapeutic or
even spiritual endeavors has been
concerned as much with the moral
personality of the thinker as with the
characteristic features of their thought
Foucault sometimes called this an
aesthetic of existence in a now
well-known description to which indeed
Foucault was indebted the historian of
the ancient world appeared at all
suggested that what was entailed in this
orientation articulated variously but
connectedly
by the Stoics and the Epicureans was not
just a specific
type of moral conduct though this tool
was important but a motive existing in
the world order one that had to be
practiced attentively and continuously
and whose aim was not purely mental but
involved the transformation of the whole
of the individual's life by the same
token the goal of this orientation was
not truth or not exactly not as
understood by rival academic
philosophers rather the goal was a
quality of attunement better thought of
as wisdom philosophy as a way of life
was directed toward the cultivation of
wisdom even while recognizing the
impossibility of its ultimate
realization and real wisdom was taken to
be less a matter of the right
application of theorems or technical
jargon than the striving involved in
being becoming different than one
already is I'm not going to belabor this
distinction between philosophy as an
abstract academic discipline and
philosophy as an art of living any more
than I need to I will in any case return
to it briefly at the end when I reflect
on one dimension of host your Hall
practiced and attunement to finding and
changing himself but I hope you can
already discern why it might be useful
here in setting in motion my reflections
on halls intellectual mode of being
arguably many of those we think of as
shaping something like a black radical
tradition valued philosophy less as an
academic discipline than as an art of
living certainly Halla stood the title
philosophy as the covering name for his
particular brand of thinking the
grandiosity the conceit not to say the
Euro centricity of the whole
philosophical posture for him the
Academy was merely one kind
of pedagogical occasion one aspect of
which was the institutionalization of
epistemological routine it was no it was
by no means the guarantee of the
authenticity or authority of thinking in
any case thinkers such as Hall who
practice an art of living or thinkers
whose thinking forms a constitutive
dimension of a reflect of a reflective
form of life think variously of Frantz
Fanon sylvia winter WB Dubois burn
abroad bah have no real need for
authenticating or authorizing labels
their thinking is not easily separable
from their lives what they think and how
cannot be cleanly disentangled from who
they are from their personal and moral
identities and therefore their thinking
is inseparable from their individuality
and from their style if Stewart Hall
seemed always to live within shouting
distance as he might have said of a
range of affiliations and solidarity's
and commitments multiple ways of being
with various others he was nevertheless
an unmistakably singular individual
inimitable his own unrepeatable voice
and presence I think of this singular
individuality as involving intimations
of an ethical passion and I think of the
pivot of this passion its animating
ethos as having been his vivid sense of
displacement of ever being at odds of
never quite corresponding to a
completely settled composite of himself
there is a lot to say about the way Hall
practiced and art of living as
displacement or through displacement in
particular how it gave point and
inflection to his style how it seasoned
the soul
his disposition how it salted the
restlessness of his spirit how it
conditioned his reflective consciousness
and I will try to say some of it here my
whole point though to give it to you at
the outset and all at one goal will be
to suggest that although displacement
would become so to speak his hermeneutic
handle the covering name for a
conceptual family of technical or
theoretical preoccupations including for
example his special uses of the ideas of
identity and diaspora it was more than
that it was the name for a primary form
of experience the name in other words of
a habitus he knew it before he could
spell it to use allocution he was fond
of he embodied it before he had a
theoretical language with which to
articulate it here in any case are the
four notes note one not surprisingly as
I think about the back about his
biography one of my central questions is
how to understand Stuart Hall in
relation to Jamaica by this I mean how
to think the senses in which Jamaica
that is his formative experience of the
geopolitical Jamaica between 1932 when
he was born and 1951 when he left for
Oxford thus the cultural historical
Jamaica he in some relevant sense
embodied helped to shape the distinctive
intellectual eventually became in what
sense should you make a matter to
telling the story of Stuart Hall or
again how might we generatively connect
Hall to a Jamaican specificity how am I
thinking with and through Jamaica help
us to understand something about the
intellectual who came to be committed to
an art of living
I don't think these are straightforward
or easily answered questions it is true
that my recently published books
Gerald's voice was not expressly
concerned with Viagra with with a
biographical direction of inquiry there
for better or worse the questions that
concerned me namely Stuart Hall's
responsive voice as a resident dimension
of a dialogical ethics of receptive
generosity of a practice of giving that
was also an openness to receiving were
framed by an exploratory consideration
of intellectual friendship of what we
owe to those whose work we admire and
honor I might now say in retrospect that
since friendship is precisely a
dimension of an arts of living I am
still working within the wider penumbra
of these considerations
however the question how to understand
Hall in relation to Jamaica is directly
relevant to how I no want to think
biographically about the relation
between his life and his work or his
work as in part at least an expressive
embodiment of the art of his life
moreover as some of you might know the
sense in which he might be thought of as
Jamaican wasn't unimportant to Stuart
Hall himself or anyway complicated and
intangible as it was it seemed to become
more and more important to him
especially in his later more retiring
years perhaps in part as growing older
growing old altered the temporal frame
in which the present could be connected
to the experience of a past and to the
expectation of a future age as we know
is a perverse prospective modifier one
is reminded of that luminous moment in
derek walcott sonata life
when the poet laments that quote a man
leaves half of life the second half is
memory unquote Walcott of course was
obsessive about the right to lis
implications of growing old but still
there is something there in what he says
about the way as the future seems to
contract as a time of active possibility
the remembered past looms larger and
larger and not necessarily as a
transparent time of easily reconstructed
effect producing causes but almost
certainly as a hermeneutic opacity or at
least a repeating puzzle as the prospect
of new beginnings recede so the question
of the past's relation to the present
grows in force and consequence I think
that in some measure over the years as
the question I think sorry in some
measure over the years the question of
his relation to Jamaica expanded swell
in halls imagination reflecting on his
reluctant decision to participate in a
conference held in his honor in Jamaica
in 2004 he remarked that while he had
spent a great deal of time thinking
about dilemmas other than those
concerning Caribbean people it seemed to
him nevertheless that he had always been
doing so quote through the prism of his
Caribbean formation unquote what could
he possibly Mina famously Hall resisted
autobiography he resisted telling the
authoritative story of himself how he
became Stewart Hall how Stewart Hall
became him memoir wasn't intuitively his
metier he was an essayist by inclination
and temperament but having resisted
autobiography for so long he oddly found
himself in the middle of 1:1 moreover
that he couldn't quite finish
and yet couldn't quite let go of I've
talked about this before and won't
repeat it here the paradox of writing in
the last conjuncture the ways in which
the memoir was an uncannily difficult
writing form for him in as much as it
demanded a certain relation to time and
especially the finitude and therefore a
temporal relation to the self that
couldn't quite be settled once and for
all through a memorial retrospective
panoptic
seeing it all at the end of a day that
would not yield to another the memoir
form is a consummate time stopper it
preempts Futurity and halt thrived
precisely on the possibility in the
present of the future displacing the
past but they remained and remains the
persisting question who anyway was due
at home and how had the Stewart Hall
come to occupy so central a place in the
in the intellectual history of the 20th
century why did so many people from so
many different domains of intellectual
and artistic life from different
generations and ethnicities converge on
or depart from Stewart Hall
it wasn't self-evident not least to
Stuart Hall himself
what meaning to attach to this there
seemed not surprisingly a haunting
element of of overdetermination at play
here
something that evaded easy
identification
or clarification more than this it made
for an ironic on settling form of
subject/object experience as Hall
suggested himself on more than one
occasion it was as though he would from
time to time turn a corner and
unexpectedly find himself fleetingly
face to face with the figure of someone
called Stuart Hall that people were
talking about occasionally I recognized
he wrote I sort of know him he has a
sort of familiarity now and again but
this experience of as it were
experienced experiencing oneself from
the outside as another Anitha sort of
person next door is uncanny it is like
being exposed to a serialized set of
embarrassments unquote this figurative
Stuart Hall that existed beyond him that
was never securely within his control
seemed to require some biographical
explanation or or anyway some narrative
location from a certain point in his
career as we know he was forever
accounting for others chapters of the
story of himself in Brittany those
chapters especially that had to do for
example with the historic making of the
first new left or with cultural studies
or with the conjuncture of Thatcherism
but Hall also perceived a deeper more
complicated story to be told a story
that involved an enigma of departure as
much as an enigma of arrival a story of
the place he left behind
yet carried with him a story that is to
say of Jamaica in short Hall found that
he too had to reconstruct the story of
Stuart Hall from the beginning so to
speak and this is the story he tells in
characteristically oblique and mediated
fashion in familiar stranger the first
installment of his memoir as with
everything he wrote this reconstruction
became really more an exploration a way
less of writing autobiography strictly
speaking as a comprehensive account then
as a process of clarifying first of all
to himself the constituent elements of
the long journey he had made to who he
had become the memoir became a way of
learning and also of learning
hope to learn something about himself
something perhaps he already knew in
some inchoate
embryonic form but couldn't but could
now encounter from another point of view
and part of what he discovered recovered
to use a couplet he especially liked
about himself I believe and tried to
articulate was that his life had a
resonant shape that belonged not merely
to himself but to the modern world that
is the colonial story of Jamaica or to
put it slightly differently what he
discovered recovered was that the
colonial Jamaica from which he came was
not an incidental dimension of the
universal history of modernity but
precisely an exemplifying index of it
and therefore who he was say as a
colonial was an embodiment of one of the
forms in which the ethos of modern life
made and expressed itself no two
as I say Stewart Hall was a singular in
intellectual he inhabited the world in
his own way with an with an unmistakable
presence what we miss when we miss him
is that his presence erudite inclusive
even tempered generous what made him
distinctive as an intellectual I believe
and I said this is my argument in Stuart
Hall's voice is less the substantive
content of the subject-matter of his
thought than the content of the forum of
his ever unfinished thinking as
everybody knows Hall was an intellectual
of wide and multiple preoccupations he
staked avaricious claim in many debates
from Marxism to media studies the
popular culture to the visual arts and
in each of these debates what he added
to them or how he changed them has
become an indispensable aspect of his
legacy and our inheritance but Stuart
Hall was more than the sum total of his
separate or interconnected contributions
to the intellectual history of our time
he was much more than the sum total of
his many ideas who he was as an
intellectual exceeded the specific and
celebrated views on thatch essay or on
the end of the essential vac subject
indeed these views are what they are
because of who he was not the other way
around in other words he was who he was
as an intellectual by dint of his style
by style though I do not mean something
merely decorative or ornamental like a
mannerism or a flourish something
external and thus detachable from
something else
taken to be the central core of his work
rather I mean what I take George lambing
to have meant when he wrote of Edgar
metal holes so that quote nothing
matters more than a man's
coveri of his style a discovery which is
also part of his own creation and style
not a style but style as the aura and
essence the recognized example of being
in which and out of which a man's life
assumes its shape the flavor of his
thinking the furious silences that fill
his heart and finally his function the
work that chooses him and for which
there is no alternative no other
instruments he can select to fulfill
that choice these constitute the style
of a man unquote style is the soul of an
art of living for all I believe style
defying the content of the form of his
thinking acting being it was not a
merely contingent aspect of that
thinking acting being it was
constitutive of it what characterized
Stuart Hall was a certain sensibility a
certain attunement a certain texture of
understanding by which I mean a certain
way of coming at the world the gestalt
of an existential attitude that was the
style of his habitus and if we had to
give a name a covering name to this
style and this attitude it would be a
sense of displacement here perhaps is
the center of what I want to get at this
afternoon fundamental to Stuart Hall's
experience of himself in the world was
his sense of displacement this is a word
that he used constantly in talking about
himself it is all over the text of
familiar stranger who lived in and
through displacement in all its ramify
resonances and implications including
importantly the psychic once he was
fully aware for example of the of
psychoanalysis as one of the provenances
of displacement as a technical term
one that Freud used to talk about dream
work in particular the way the
unconscious lives in the world through
substitutions condensations
postponements and other decentering
mediations displacement was what you
might call an experience near concept
for him in any case a good deal of halls
moral psychological sensibility can be
thought of in terms of this to him
founding sense of himself as being in
the phrase he liked to borrow from
Edward Sayid out of place it captured
almost everything about him
Hall understood himself to be
constitutive and constitutively and
forever out of place and much of his
genius consists of the way in which he
learned to use this sense of
displacement of not quite corresponding
to a presumed norm of self and society
as a kind of hermeneutic lens through
which to approach and critique the world
displacement became in effect the model
for his very idea of thinking for whole
thinking worth the name depended on an
unknown identity upon the non identity
of the subject and object in an intimate
way it was for him the discrepancy the
difference the non correspondence
between the Stuart Hall for example of
his own experience and the figure the
Stuart Hall that would become he said a
possibility for his own thinking and I
quote again there is a sense in which
one has to stand back outside of oneself
in order to make the detour through
thought to approach what one is trying
to think about indirectly obliquely in
another way another mode I think that
the world is fundamentally resistant to
thought I do not think it wants to be
understood so inevitably
thinking is hard work a kind of labor it
is not something that simply flows
naturally from inside once
unquote notice that the world including
ourselves as part of that world is not
readily thinkable readily discursive all
the world including ourselves as part of
that world is not merely transparent
appearance notice then how thinking for
Hall was not a self-evident activity but
a mediated labor of creative
displacement and how his own experience
of himself could become the ground of
his hermeneutic understanding he didn't
know this automatically it wasn't a
self-evident fact given like a gift to
him by the world it was a fact he
suggests he had to earn by learning it
and relearning it and one of the way and
one way of expressing what he learned to
do is to say that he learned to think
through the unnamed Jamaican in himself
and to think through it in such a way as
to render that experience of Jamaica at
acid form of universality in other words
what he learned gradually to do was to
make the experience of displacement that
was as George lambing might have said
native to his person the implicit and
explicit basis of his relation to
theoretical understanding as such he did
this of course not so much by writing
substantively or extensively about
Jamaica which he didn't do but by
writing out of the social historical
features and moral psychological
textures that provided the unconscious
background of his fundamental experience
of himself note three
so how might we usefully think of the
sources of this ground of displacement
again working in relation to the
question of biography I believe that
halls familial and social origins in the
Jamaican Brown middle class are a
founding location for the emergence of
this experience of displacement at least
in latent form Hall's parents Herman and
Jesse Hall belonged to a distinct
fragment of this class I won't go into
the wide-ranging sociological details
here suffice it to say that the elder
halls seem to have embodied the familiar
ethos and values of the brown
middle-class self consciousness
obsessive self consciousness of color
and class and social advancement a
preoccupation with respectability and
propriety decorum the cultivation of
good taste manners and so on and to have
produced for the young Stuart at their
apparently meticulously organized and
well-appointed home on Trevanian Park
Road in 1930s and 1940s Kingston the
subtle and not so subtle approach
enhances of grown middle-class life it
is in this context that in a pre
theoretical way he comes to embody
displacement as a as a kind of primary
experience that displacement comes to
acquire the quality of second nature
that informed a given tendency of
dispositions or habitus and that would
become the implicit background resource
for his later more self-consciously
reflective or theoretical ideas because
again note that in my view for Hall
displacement was first and foremost not
a theory but a sense of the world a
sensing of the world less the way he
self-consciously came to the world than
the founding way in which the world came
to
in the elementary form of
intelligibility now some of you probably
know the Jamaican brown middle class is
a peculiar social psychological and
historical formation it is a formation I
believe that we have not thought about
sufficiently in a defective or non
fictive work still in my view anyway
given its singularly contradictory and
fundamental role in the making of modern
Jamaica it is a social formation that
deserves far more critical attention
than it has so far attracted among
several possible directions for example
there is surely a psychoanalytic story
waiting to be written about the internal
libidinal structuring of this social
formation the way historically it has
lived its sense of distinction and where
these touch on the most intimate and my
new aspects of its social personal and
emotional existence the defining social
and affective experience of this middle
class what ian hacking would call its
historical ontology is precisely
displacement that is it's unsettled
tormented inability to be what it is to
find a restful home in a given identity
indeed one might say and not
irrelevantly given Stuart Hall's later
preoccupations it is partly the fact of
displacement that stimulated in this
formation its anxious and frustrated
obsessions with the very idea of its
national identity but what is it about
this middle class that encourages an
original experience of displacement how
might we think of this founding sense of
displacement as coming to form the
ground of a larger way of being in and
thinking through the world speaking in
an excessively shorthand and perhaps
even somewhat reductive way it is
important to bear in mind that the
Jamaican brown middle class was
historically born within and out of the
social contradictions and sexual
violations
depredations of colonial plantation
slavery in a certain very relevant sense
it was born already out of place
anomalous an excrescence within a social
economic order principally organized
around a black-white enslaved free
racial binary in this racial dynamic the
brown middle class belonged to neither
one pole nor the other it lived rather
in a structurally indissoluble
ambivalence in one direction in
disavowal of any proximity with
blackness including the blackness within
itself in another direction in
aspiration of material and symbolic
identification with whiteness in a
profound social cultural and
psychological sense neither this
disavowal nor this aspiration was
completely realized completely
realizable and therefore what defines
the Brown middle class is the way it has
lived perpetually unevenly
in a non resolve of the tension or
anxiety of belonging as Hall later
recognized born as he was in 1932 he
grew up inside this brown middle-class
formation as it negotiated a period of
unprecedented upheaval marked by the
modernizing social and political
revolution of 1938 to 1944 that is the
period between the labor riots and the
reforms that initiated constitutional
decolonization for this was a
conjuncture in hall sense in which the
spontaneous revolt of the black urban
and rural working-class in effect pried
open a political space that enabled the
aspiring nationalists Brown middle class
to at last begin to mobilize a
successful claim for its right to rule
in this sense constitutional
decolonization was a project of
middle-class
but if this was a moment of tremendous
possibility for politically progressive
sections of the nationalist middle class
seeing before itself the luminous
prospect of getting its hands on the
reins of government it was also a moment
of threat and loss for another section
one numerically smaller perhaps but not
insignificant that could only see the
coming future of nation state
sovereignty as the looming ruin of the
old colonial Jamaica although we
sometimes think of it this way as a
consequence no doubt of the
retrospective normalization of the
nationalist narrative historically the
brown middle class was never a
homogenous formation certainly in the
1940s when Stewart grew up they were not
all committed nationalists so not
uniformly so not an unambiguously so it
shouldn't be surprising therefore that
whereas there were those who came to see
themselves in the mirror of nationalism
there were also those who looked to the
future with a mixture perhaps of fear
and resignation among these were Stuart
Hall's parents Herman and Jesse he
always said
they were not like our imagined norm of
the nationalist Brown middle class and
this is what he meant
they never warmed to the ideology of
national self-determination it's not
clear they welcomed the democratizing
adult suffrage constitution of 1944 that
brought the black working class into the
formal field of politics undoubtedly for
their fragment of the middle class their
disavows and aspirations must only have
been intensified by their increasing
anachronism their growing social and
political relevance in this context one
can only imagine how the rituals of
brown middle-class pretension and
repression the unreal realities of life
at Trevanian Park Road must have
registered in a contradictory way on the
youngster Hall
I say contradictory here because the
paradox says he would have been the
first to point out is that you had
necessarily to be it in order to be able
to organically recoil from it as he did
you have to already embody the class
color habitus into which you have been
installed in some form in order to live
its pretensions and repressions in an
equally embodied dissenting refusal that
is not merely as ideology but as a
foundational decentering of moral
psychological identity inscribed in the
primary experience of a divide itself
for self division in a word is the
distinctive mark of the Jamaican Brown
middle class halls self-consciousness of
his journey
indeed his self-consciousness of himself
as a kind of itinerary is the story of
constantly negotiating the trace as he
would say of that original structure he
was always preoccupied with the way in
which an outside quote unquote
comes to be lived on or as and inside
that is to say the way large social
historical processes are transmuted into
lived experiences within a family say or
how a social and political economy comes
to be installed psychically in an
individual's libidinal economy as with
everything he talked about this relation
between an inside and an outside was
never perceived in a reductive way the
psyche for example was never a mere
reflection of the social rather what
compelled him as one version of the
relation between the general and the
particular or the social and individual
or the historical and the psychological
was the contradictory perhaps partly
Fantas Matic way a family comes to
embody in a mediated or thus entered or
displaced we
the social contradictions of a
particular history or further how a
child comes to embody again in a
mediated or dissented or displaced we in
the domain and language of the
unconscious the layered burdens of both
social and the familiar it is this
experience of the Brown mill classes
alienation from itself I believe not
merely the ante popular or elitist
character or cultural politics but but
its moral psychological betrayal of
something of itself its destructive
racial self-hatred that founds halls
constitutional sense of non
correspondence and therefore of
displacement again my point almost my
whole point is that part of what makes
him the singular intellectual he became
was to have been able to transmute this
pre theoretical habitus into a
hermeneutic by which to conceptually
understand the world in other words in
my view it is not so much the content of
the theory of identity or diaspora see
that bears consideration as the
sensibility that draws him to them as
conceptual windows the attunement to the
texture of a modern racialized colonial
experience that solicits from him the
demand for a theory of them it is this
to my mind that makes your whole so
distinctive and intellectual note for
finally I want to talk a bit about Hall
in relation to the ethical life that I
believe was implicit in his practice of
an intellectual art of living but
ethical life I do not mean anything very
abstract or abstruse anything
excessively
regalian say let alone live in ASEAN
nope both have their relevance I mean
simply to evoke a vital background I
mentioned two halls way of carrying on
his self examined intellectual life the
temper and orientation of the values and
virtues through which that life as a
life that cultivated human excellencies
was actualized I keep saying that what
interests me about Hall is not the
content of his views so much as his way
of having views and indeed his way of
changing his views this is what I'm
calling his style and that style
connoted and disclosed an ethics an
idiom of on formalized attitudes that
shaped his presence as much as his
practice I will try to connect this
ethics to my exploratory description of
his experience of being a Jamaican as I
have been saying a particular primary
experience of displacement lent to halt
some of the basic elements sort of which
he developed his mature cultural
political style and vocabulary and also
therefore the tacit idiom of his ethics
or to put it another way and in the form
of a question how might one described
the sort of reflective consciousness
disclosed in Stuart Hall's work it is
obvious I think that Hall's was a
profoundly reflective consciousness that
is a consciousness that lived in a
perpetually self questioning
but I do not think that it is enough to
merely say that he was self questioning
in his mode of intellectual practice
because there are obviously many ways of
being reflectively self-conscious one
way I have been trying to describe
Hall's distinctive more with a
reflective being his self-conscious way
of being the intellectual he sought to
be is by thinking of him as a listening
self it's an idea I borrow from the work
of Michael Levin I've developed this
idea at length in my book Stuart Hall's
voice in particular the contrast between
a critical and a listening self the
former shaped in various ways by
hermeneutics of suspicion and the latter
again in various ways by a hermeneutics
of attunement it is easy to see how one
might however imperfectly map this
contrast onto the one I sketched earlier
between a philosophy thought of as a
theoretical discourse and philosophy
understood as a way of life a
hermeneutics of receptivity is exactly
what the wisdoms of a way of life entail
but I'm not going to return exactly to
the idea of a listening self here rather
I want to focus on another though
connected dimension of hall's ethical
mode would have intellectual life one
concerned with his capacity for self
Constitution and self revision you will
recall that in Pierre a--does
formulation mentioned earlier this
capacity for self engagement is
precisely one of the characteristics of
an informed art of living and here irony
might be a useful dimension to consider
so in an admittedly exploratory way I
want to layer the idea of a listening
self with that of an ironic one might
one say of Stuart Hall that his was an
ironic life no I wanted to be clear that
I'm not using ironic here in the
conventional sense to suggest something
the linguistic namely saying one thing
while meeting another rather I'm using
it in much the way it has been used by
some recent thing because among them
Richard Bernstein Jonathan Lear
Alexander Nia master suggests less a
figure of speech
than a form of experience and an
orientation to life on this view an IRA
nest is not a metaphysician but a
practitioner of an art of living one
specifically that cultivates a readiness
for disruption and revision or if you
like of displacement an ironic self is
one that experiences itself has never
quite corresponding with itself it is a
self that lives with an acute sense of
its own historicity an ironic self is
attuned not only to the world as change
but to itself as potentially changeful
it acknowledges the uses of stepping
back if not all the way to nowhere it
practices not an abstract detachment
from the world or from itself but on the
contrary a passionate commitment to
receptively relating to both I think it
won't be hard to recognize dimensions of
Stuart Hall's art of living in this
brief description let me give you just
one example of what I am getting at the
example is a familiar one that Hall
himself talked about in in various of
his writings though of course not not
exactly in this way it concerns the
antinomies of his own Constitution and
self constitution of identity and it is
profoundly marked by the in eliminated
imprint or trace of Jamaica remember
that when accompanied by his implacable
mother Jesse Hall arrived in England in
1951 to take up his roads he was by his
own account a bright young man with a
sound grammar school education and
emerging if still inchoate political
and above all a longing for the modern
this arrival in England coincidentally
converged with their with the arrival of
thousands of West Indian migrants large
numbers of them Jamaican it was the
beginnings of the so called Windrush
generation that would alter the
landscape of contemporary Britain and
some of you might be aware of the
incredible scandal around this
generation as it as it ages and requires
medical attention and so forth in
contemporary Britain these were men and
women who were decidedly not by the
prevailing norms like halt in class or
color or education but there were people
with whom he began uncertainly to form
partly conscious partly not an
identification and post Notting Hill in
1958 a sense of solidarity now as he
tells it on one of his trips back to
Jamaica in the early nineties 1960s his
mother says to him that she hopes the
English don't mistake him for an
immigrant that is one of those black
working-class West Indians he'd seen
chaotically streaming out of Paddington
train station it is for Hall a radical
or rupturing moment of self D
Constitution and self reconstitution to
this point his identity has principally
been as a participant in the project of
the new left then in transition but he
instantly recognizes in his mother's
tendentious remark the perverse Massa
nations of brown middle-class racism
then the neurotic disavows through which
she was seeking to distance him from the
abject stain of blackness and to
reinstall him into the hegemonic place
of his social origins and not only does
he recoil from the unavoidable negative
psychological impact but in the same
moment he finds
in it the positive reflective ground for
renaming his sense of displacement and
animating it moreover with specific
cultural political content yes he says
to himself I too am an immigrant and
indeed as the immigrant emerges in the
middle and late 1960s as a politicized
category especially in the context of
Enoch Enoch Powell's rivers of blood
ideology Hall finds himself speaking
before such audiences as the National
Committee for Commonwealth immigrants
but almost as soon as this moment of
decentering has acquired a usable
vocabulary and a plausible effective
salience by the end of the 1960's almost
as soon as he has gotten the hang so to
speak of being an immigrant he's once
again unexpectedly dissenter thrown off
balance by a new set of social and
existential forces for while he was
being an immigrant a new generation was
emerging including his own children
largely born in Britain who were
influenced by the militancy of Rastafari
and reggae and black power and who saw
themselves not in the me in the demeanor
of the supplicant colored immigrant but
as black with an assertive claim to make
on the British state and the civic
institutions of British society a new
cultural political language was emerging
it was emerging in a slightly different
way in Jamaica - in exactly the same
moment and it is for hall another
rupturing moment of self de Constitution
and self reconstitution another intimate
moment of uncanny and ironic disruption
when he is faced with the unstable
historicity of who he is when he can no
longer simply go on occupying the old
identity immigrant he too is black he
discovers recovers and he must now
confront the implication for himself
both personal and political of getting
the hang of being black of recovering
discovering the idiom of a black
identity of thinking and acting in the
name of a black subjectivity being black
wasn't exactly natural to him he says
but it wasn't exactly not he didn't grow
up that way in that language he had to
grow into it he had to learn to be what
in part he already was identity might
well be constructed but it isn't he said
merely a journey of the mind now the
point I'm making in recounting this
example it's specific content
notwithstanding is less that Stuart Hall
eventually grew to think of himself as
black or even that as a way of
theorizing the process he invented the
famous idea of the end of innocence of
essential black subject both important
in themselves of course rather my whole
point my larger point and this is where
I will end is that what we see here is
an instance of the ethics of Stuart
Hall's art of living in this placement
it is an instance of his capacity in
shifting conjunctures to
self-consciously take stock of himself
the courage to open himself to the
experience is a novel of an upheaval of
identity in himself and to be able to
respond receptively and creatively and
personally to the demands embodied in
the attendant rupture I do not say that
it was a seamlessly perfect endeavor
without inconsistency or contradiction I
do not suggest that there weren't limits
to his receptivity to changefulness
that there weren't modes of living and
idioms of individuality and sociality
beyond his capacities for a tune meant
he was human after all but nevertheless
I believe we have in this example an
instance of the kind of reflective
consciousness that he sought to educate
in himself and encouraged in others as a
way of he would say living with
difference the differences within
oneself and between oneself and others
and I'd say that learning to live with
difference is another way of learning to
live with irony learning to live with a
sensibility that registers
responsiveness to the idea that human
being is never transparent never has
simply never a simple seamlessly
self-evident totality but lived in off
multiple mediated iterations of division
and self division lived in short in
displacement and non correspondence
these two whole were integral aspects of
our human forms of life and what I'm
saying is that his sense of displacement
and non correspondence group hardly out
of his own primary experience of them
out of the prism he might have said of
the idiom of his Jamaican formation
thank you
I see taking a deep breath for the one
requirement is that you be gentle well
it was wonderful it was beautifully
written and wonderful in many many ways
but and I guess and I got a great sense
of the kind of earnest heart of living
of David Scott and the kind of
conversation reciprocity but it seemed I
guess the difference and I go way I can
ask the question is it missed me in
Stuart Hall's work in writing that it
was more about the care of others in the
care of the self this is a man who I
don't think ever did publish a book with
only his own name on it
at almost all the work even the memoir
that we get familiar strangers is the
publishers curry creation of it as a
memoir the original version was as an
interview series and the model I think
that he was even thinking of he wrote a
wonderful review of the series of 400
pages of interviews that the new left
review editors did with Raymond Williams
and he reflected on the power of
interview rather than memoir if I
remember it's not been recent and so I
guess I wonder about the accenting of
the self even as it is divided itself
and how much your attention to the
content of his form actually is in
tension
with the form of his content the
rhetoric of human in many ways the deep
refusal of humanism and the varieties of
that his interested you know the line
though he would move from one particular
theorist to another it does seem that
his interest from altas Iran to Foucault
to others was in many ways an attempt to
displace that foundational that sense of
founding fundamental humanity and self
for some kind of alternative way of
understanding community even in
intellectual community so I know whether
that's exactly a question thank you very
much for that your um I'm not sure where
exactly to begin I think we're I think
we're not very far from each other
[Music]
I don't think of I mean I let me begin
back from from the from where you end
Stewart as an anti humanist I don't
think so at all I don't think so at all
I think you know I okay I don't think so
at all but and part of what I mean by
that I think is that there is something
crucial for him especially in
structuralist iterations of himself in
which a kind of anti-humanist
theoretical posture was important for
the ways in which he sought to intervene
and displays various kinds of
assumptions Norman normalized selves of
various sorts or and so on so I think
there there there is a a really
important way in which a really
important way in which theorists posture
of anti humanism characterized a good
deal of his you know
separating himself from the kinds of
humanism is represented by Raymond
Williams Ricky Thompson and on and on so
I think yes but I think I think that was
also salted in some way by a humanity
that that I think is embodied in what
else were called his receptive
generosity which which you point to at
the very beginning of what you have to
say the sense that his orientation was
always an orientation to the to the
reflective consciousnesses and the
preoccupations of others but to me that
receptivity of others was partly a way
of informing himself and part of the way
in which he changed himself so I mean I
think that there is an achievement
absolutely an orientation to a
worldliness and and to others and
various kinds of others who constitute
that world but I think there was a an
attention to what was required of change
in himself that sought to meet the
contingencies in which he found himself
so I think an attentiveness to the world
of what to the world of change in others
was was was but one side of a
preoccupation with the question what
what do I need to change in myself and I
think that's part of and you know Stuart
would never talk about himself in the
terms that I have used here obviously
and so there isn't there is no theory
there's no ethical theory properly
speaking in his work I'm digging it out
in some form and and trying to look at
some of the the other sides of it by
which to refract some of the things we
in some sense many of us already know in
that attention to to others
to difference gentleness is of course
all that's required I have two questions
one one was a footnote a sociological
one so it may not be about I was
thinking about what you mean by the
brown middle-class and and part of that
is thinking about anti colonial
nationalism and hegemony and of course
the as you know more than I do from
inside the subaltern studies project
that narrative is considered unfulfilled
but it's also a polarization between an
elite and it subaltern mass and so I was
curious and this may be technical or
sociological sense in what sense is the
Brown middle class middle class and not
elite and is that in some sense about
the kind of values of a propriety or
Victorian you know conduct that you
emphasize as being the middle class list
classicness of that and the other
question I thought of when you described
displacement as being native in some
sense and pre theoretical to Stuart Hall
it also seemed to be a very spatial
category or a structure well a freudian
in in the Freudian sense very structural
category and then obviously as a
metaphor for migration departure and
arrival it has a very spatial sense but
I was thinking as a parallel to your
work on tragedy and especially in
conscripts where you're very interested
in temporal disjunction or amount of
timeless so I was just trying to think
of so it seemed that Stuart Hall has an
out of place Ness but he doesn't seem to
have an out of time Nisour I guess
that's the question and that you know in
another way that his orientation towards
the future or contingency and it just
seems an interesting question because in
the way Marx is and again the Indian
parallel Indian Marxism struggles with a
lot of temporal
it's around around what the philosophy
of history is but Stuart Paul Elyse is
writing never seemed either nostalgic or
temporally in just that our word
disjunct heard in the way that the
spatial does seem to mark something so
hmm-hmm the sociological question the
the the brown middle-class in the
Caribbean but perhaps more specifically
her Jamaican social formation becomes an
elite at certainly the nationalist elite
but in the in the context of Jamaican
historical social formation the elite
are white and the ill attack are rapidly
anti-nationalist and the colonial
project is in some way I mean and they
are the holders of up to the 1930s of
social economic and political power the
the brown middle-class the formal the in
the nineteen in the eighteenth and early
nineteenth century these are the three
colors these are folk who who emerge as
people of distinctiveness largely
through the professions because they
can't own land because they're
prohibited from owning land largely and
prevented from voting and it's an
interesting formation because by the by
the 19th century they begin very
explicitly to think of themselves as the
only Jamaicans that the black majority
come from and elsewhere and the white
minority come from from their own
elsewhere but they have this is there's
this is the only thing that they have
and by the early 20th century they are
installed as the the the the leading
thinkers of what the nation project
might me that they will inherit does
that answer does that partly yeah so
it's middle class and they say you know
in almost a quite literal sense that
they
that they are middle and they and and in
some sense never really become an
economic elite they can't transition to
economic ownership which is part of the
the conflict around race in contemporary
Jamaica that there's a reason a black
middle class that has displaced the
brown middle class voice yeah but the
second question about temporality Stuart
Hall's out of place nests but not his
out of time eNOS you know I'm not sure
exactly how to respond to there is a
certain timeliness this was Terry
Hilton's very unfortunate London Review
of Books essay about the hippest and
therefore in fact an attempt to pay
attention as he thought of it to to the
sense of timeliness of Stuart Hall's
interventions that he had away I mean in
my view at least Eagleton construct this
in a pejorative way but he's he's a
tension to a certain to the now in in
some in some in some form at the
attention to the politics of theoretical
intervention and in that sense he was
constantly asking the question about
what what time is it
and he all he would always joke I think
often with Katherine his wife was an
historian that death that is your
problem not mine the past is yours
the present is man in some form and I
think that there is something important
about not that not that history didn't
matter but but it mattered only insofar
as you could get something from it that
would enable not an epistemological
critique but the kind of political
critique that would open space for some
new kind of political action
and I think that in a in a very curious
way that sense of his own timeliness
that sense of his own Orion temporal
orientation to the not-yet of a future
to come me writing a memoir very very
difficult it made enormous ly difficult
for him to stand away from his own time
and to see his entire past up to his
present without the possible without the
possibility as he sat in his house of a
real future to come for him as an actor
an anomalous kind of temporal situation
for his own self hood so I think that
there is there is I don't think that he
was without a sense of the baggage of
the past I don't think so I think he
carried I think that in a certain sense
and this is partly what I meant by
growing old that as he began to reflect
more and more on how he became who he
was or who he was taken to be or who he
understudy to understood himself to be
that understanding as he grew older was
shaped less and less by the possibility
of new intervention and more and more by
the by the the expansiveness of a past
that he carried and a past that was not
entirely straightforwardly nameable to
him especially the Jamaican past because
his cultural theoretical language was a
language that had grown up inside of and
in relation to the struggles are on the
new left and afterwards
now is the time for a drink
thank you all thank you over now
[Applause]
[Music]